we've got heartbreak breakups and
gargoyle kings shake-up so let's break
it all down on Sweetwater secrets oh my
goodness river babes school is back in
session and we have so much to discuss
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 310 chapter 45 the stranger
which was jam-packed with plot twists
The Gargoyle King was revealed Hyrum was
shot the black hood came back into the
picture the SATs are here I just don't
even know where to begin
shut up deep breaths today I'm bringing
you exclusive new interviews with Lilly
Reinhart and KJ APPA talking all about
the episodes biggest moments so let's
jump right into all that with the blue
and gold breakdown we started off the
episode knowing immediately that Archie
is alive well kind of apparently the new
dead inside Archie returned to Riverdale
but rather than focusing on the fact
that he escaped an illegal juvie Fight
Club was attacked by high rooms farm
floozy and was just on the brink of
death his friends were focused on these
earth-shattering questions instead what
the hell happened your hair since when
do you drink root beer floats you know
it's weird when Reggie is the only one
who's asking about the things that
matter what you serious you were
attacked by a friggin bear but forget
everything because Archie was now faced
with an even bigger problem what SATs
but the pressures of the test ended up
being too much for our boy next door so
he stormed out of the room and had
another high room fuelled panic attack
in the bathroom conveniently at the same
time a very smug high room was struck by
a mysterious bullet and Ronnie was
looking to point fingers at her
redheaded boo you can even ask me that
by the end of the episode Archie found a
horrible new way to cope with all his
demons now over on the south side of
things with fangs undercover with the
gargoyle gang he tipped Jughead off to a
little tweaky ceremony and the gargoyle
King was finally revealed
well that was confusing and
underwhelming now even though the
serpens thought that he was dead top boy
revealed that he's been hiding out in
Athens and that he was in fact the one
who broke into the Cooper household and
the one who murdered Joaquin honestly I
completely forgot
about Joaquin so I didn't care but
apparently sweet peen things did later
Jughead found tallboy dead again and the
two serpents claimed that it happened
when he was trying to escape so it was
up to Giggy to find the best way to
cover up a murder we're gonna throw a
party but it looks like the serpents are
going to be just fine because there's a
new sheriff in town you're looking at
the new law in Riverdale meanwhile Alice
Cooper reached a new level of crazy
because she transferred all of Betty's
College Fund savings to the farm in
order to combat her cult loving mother
Betty had a visit her serial killer
father for some help and getting her
money back that's the only thing how
gave her was a bunch of lies the former
black hood tried to claim that he was
the original gargoyle king who killed
principal featherhead odd ascension
knight but it was really just a way to
keep Betty coming back to his creepy
class cell Oh Betty how I miss you and
our chats
Betty's college fund is officially gone
and the farm is using that money to put
their new headquarters at the sisters of
quiet mercy building because whatever
sure and Betty is now using her demented
dad as her new therapist were you
shocked to see how Cooper again in this
episode yeah so was Lily Reinhardt so
take a look at what she told me when I
asked her about Betty's father-daughter
reunion you know I think at this point
Betty she still doesn't trust him that's
why she questions everything that he
says but I think she's desperate to
figure out who the gargoyle king is and
trying to put this mystery together that
she's been questioning the whole season
so far so she's gonna get what you can
out of him and hopefully use whatever
information he gives whether he's lying
or not is the question but you know
they're not solving anything together
they're not a team but I I think she's
just using any resources that she can it
just so happens to be her dad I just
wanted some father-daughter time he's a
very manipulative guy but he's also her
father and it's like he does have a pole
to her and they somehow find a
connection again
and I'm not saying it's good but I think
it's a very interesting plot line and it
was very fun to go back and shoot
because I really love that set yeah it's
like Silence of the Lambs Hannibal
Lecter and still behind the glass yes
it's amazing and we that set is fun to
shoot on we play a lot with reflections
and kind of like seeing each other see
the glass it's really cool do you think
Betty you should trust how are you over
the whole black hood thing hit the
comments below and tell me with your
thoughts
but now let's shift our attention from
jailbirds to lovebirds in this week 7
seconds in heaven ok so even though
there was no Shoni or phallus in this
episode and all we got from bug-head was
a sweet little forehead kiss I still
suggest you river babes grab a neck
brace cuz we're about to get romantic
whiplash from all of our chief edgy back
and forth in this episode at first
tensions were high when Veronica first
saw Archie was back in town but within
the first 5 seconds of reuniting Bart
she was back to doing well what they do
best wait hold up Vee what about Reggie
yeah you know the guy you were literally
just smooching on for the first time
last week Reggie
cool it Archie's back Wow
ok cool actually not cool Vee that was
harsh in fact I almost didn't mind when
an anxiety filled Archie ditched your
espanol solo but Reggie sure was fired
up about it I'm talking about how you
stormed out of this speakeasy like a
little [ __ ] Andrews as if that wasn't
obvious enough Reggie also accidentally
spilled the veggie beans to Archie but
just as it looked like V was about to
break things off with her man they
decided to postpone their pain so they
could enjoy a night of pleasure but once
Hiram was shot and he made it clear she
thought that Archie was the top suspect
things with Marty came to a screeching
halt it's over isn't it but jazz the
look who was waiting there to help me
pick up the pieces
Reggie goodness gracious that was a
whole lot of love triangle trauma and if
you're like me then you need some
insider answers luckily for you I sat
down with KJ app' and asked him all
about Archie's mindset in this episode
and here's what he had to say yeah it's
interesting I think you know the time
that they spend a part they meet people
as you do and I think they're kind of on
different roads when he comes back and I
feel like there's definitely potential
for them to meet back again but I think
at the moment we know when he comes back
I don't think he's in the right
headspace and I don't think she has the
time to kind of invest in that
relationship
how is Archie going to react when he
discovers that there's now a new
potential romance blossoming between
Veronica and Reggie I think he gets it I
don't think I choose the kind of person
who I mean he wasn't expecting her to
wait around for him and he made that
pretty clear you know during the phone
call so yeah I mean they're really good
friends and I think you know he's
probably happier that it's someone that
he knows that would take care of her
instead of some you know the random dude
maybe do you think there's still a
chance for Veronica and Archie to get
back together oh for sure this is
Riverdale what do you think River babes
are you hoping barchi rises once again
or are you ready to see more VeggieTales
or who else thinks that Veronica should
be single tell me in the comments but
then let's continue this thought process
as we dive into hisses and kisses my
first hit of the night is honestly well
it's going to miss her on a collage and
no does it's not just because two
ridiculously attractive boys are vying
for her attention although I mean come
on it isn't fair no I'm sending hisses -
the fact that she kind of treated both
her boys like crap in this episode now
first she ghosted Reggie the second her
archiekins walked back into town and
then she was a little too quick to
accuse Archie of shooting Hiram
newsflash Veronica your dad sucks and he
has a lot of enemies and last time I
checked you were one of them now
personally I'm putting my money on the
fact that Hermione shot him but anyways
long rant short all I'm saying is that I
think you need to be single for a little
bit now be alright don't disagree
next up hisses the tallboy for being
revealed as The Gargoyle King are you
freaking kidding me
that was so frustrating stop with the
death fake outz I'm tired of it I'm also
gonna take this time to double down on
my bets and say that I think this is
just another black hood fake out you
know like when tallboy was supposedly
the black hood he's big but he's the guy
who was he gerald petit also known as
tall boy yeah there's no way that the
real gargoyle King is tall boy the
Twiggs just don't add up
also I'm sending hisses to claudius
blossom why well it
like I should mention his death at some
point in the Sweetwater episode but I
also think that his entire distance in
Riverdale was so pointless so there you
go he's useless gone now let's shake off
this negative energy and focus on some
kisses shall we now the biggest kiss of
the episode is actually going to hire
them but don't get too smug dude I'm
sending a kiss to the fact that you were
shot it was glorious oh and can we
please all send a massive kiss to Fred
Andrews he may look sweet but he
reminded us what a true badass he is
when he's threatened Hiram Lodge Hyrum
if you harm a hair on Archie's head I
will kill you oh he's still my beating
hot dad's of Riverdale loving heart and
while we're on the snow kisses 2fp for
becoming the new sheriff
sheriff Jones now boy and lastly kisses
to principal Weatherbee for saying the
most realistic thing we've heard on
Riverdale in a long time I would
strongly recommend that you repeat your
junior year don't look so shocked Archie
you went to juvie first thing in
September and you've been on the run for
almost an entire semester also I'm
shocked that you even passed your
sophomore year given the fact that you
were Hiram's little henchmen at all
hours of the day I'm in high school how
am I supposed to know that you need to
start doing homework babe I think we're
beyond that point don't you and we're
gonna end it there now thank you all so
much for tuning in and be sure to check
back with me next time for our
Sweetwater secrets preview show for
Episode three eleven chapter 46 the Red
Dahlia for even more exclusive
interviews with the stars but for now
you know what to do please give this
video a like hit subscribe and then head
on down to the comments to tell me your
hisses and kisses for the episode are
you team of Archie veggie or neither
were you disappointed by the tallboy
twist who do you think shot Hyrum and
should Archie be held back tell me
everything you're thinking and I'm
sending kisses right to you river babes
see ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]